Happy New Year's everybody for a lot of
you this might be a turning point in
your life a new beginning the world
didn't end we're not all going to die
we're still held accountable for the
mistakes we've made in the past
and I've been thinking a lot about how
the years the more just in the past two
years have changed my life in a lot of
ways because 2011 was not a good year
for me a lot of the things were out of
my hands you know the tumor and
everything and appendectomy and other
stuff were out of my hand but I also
made a lot of dumb mistakes the kind of
mistakes people do when they don't know
any better and 2012 came around and I
was taken aback by the response I got
from something simple that I created and
it's not even that unique or not neat or
anything I just used the talents that I
had to craft something that you all seem
to enjoy and for some reason I've gotten
50,000 subscribers from that over 50
almost 55 thousand subscribers now and I
got to thinking of what I should do with
that you know what I need to do with
that and charity is something that's
always been very important to me because
I've been fortunate but a lot of people
have not there are kids that are
suffering every day from potentially
curable diseases 'i'm not just kids but
people everywhere around the world
there's starvation you know in the world
today it's hard to understand being that
a lot of people in America where I live
don't get that but even in America
there's a lot of starvation
people suffering everyday and I can't
stand around and just watch it happen
when I have the power to do something
right in front of my face so my new
year's resolution this year is to raise
a bare minimum by the end of this year
fifty thousand dollars for charity and I
can do that well I can't do that
personally but through you guys we can
do that because we've got over fifty
thousand subscribers right now if
everyone chipped in a dollar we meet our
goal
somehow I've been thrust into this
leader position we're allowed to use a
lot of you guys and gals out there
believe in me and that's something that
reminded me of this comic that I read a
long time ago I can't find it anymore
I've looked I can't find it but it was
describing the process of how if someone
believes in something so passionately
that they eventually catch fire in
regards to that subject and that fire
can inspire other people around them the
smoke builds and people start looking at
this person that believes in something I
want to be that person that believes
that they can help the world and help
change something for the better I've
always advocated that we need to build a
community that believes in helping
everyone around us and we can do that we
could do that 50,000 subscribers ago we
can do that even more now you know we've
already raised seven thousand dollars
for charity that was going from you know
when I started I didn't have many people
to raise and my first goal for my first
charity livestream was a thousand
dollars but I wanted to let you guys
know that there is a charity livestream
coming up this Saturday this Saturday
one two three
four days from now four days from now
starting at 10 a.m. Eastern Standard
Time on Saturday there's a link to my
twitch channel in the description below
click on that follow me you'll know
exactly when I go live we're gonna be
raising five thousand dollars for an
organ donation charity that my friend
Tyler Scheid he's going to be there too
he had to get a kidney transplant at a
very young age and it kind of threw a
wrench in a lot of his plans but he's
still one of the most fun guys I know
he's always smiling and always can crack
a joke he's a great guy so uh he's gonna
pick the charity I don't know what it is
just yet but he's gonna throw me some
offerings and we're gonna get that
organized but I believe that we can do
so much more
I believe with every fiber of my being
that we can do so much more because the
more people we get the more people we
organize around this common goal the
more that we can do cuz I tell a lot of
you I may just be a guy that plays games
online then that's it that's fine but
know that I want to be more than that I
want to do so much more with what I have
money for me has never been important
but money for charities is absolutely
important because there are so many
people out there that are suffering and
people turn a blind eye to them every
day and I can't sit around and watch
that happen anymore my new year's
resolution to my life has to be based
around helping other and making an
impact and I hope that you all feel the
same because I want I want to believe
that other people believe what I believe
I just I want to be passionate about
something I want to make a difference
so I hope you'll all be there this
Saturday to join me and I hope you all
take this year as an example
to turn something around in your life
where something that you can change you
know a lot of things are out of your
control but there are so many things
that can be in your control because New
Year's resolutions are just words unless
you act upon them you have to find that
one thing that you burn passionately for
and if you do don't let it go of it for
anything people are going to tell you
that you can't just because they can and
you have to keep moving forward no
matter what drags you down no matter
what has dragged you down your past
the things that have happened to you bad
luck whatever it can't drag you down or
else you'll stay down and you'll never
be able to get back up after a while
you'll get you'll start wallowing in
this pit of despair where you know you
blame others for the mistakes and it may
be their fault but you can't let that
change your life so I hope you all take
this year as an example because well
we're still here end of the world didn't
happen
we all have to move forward and we all
have to make the world a better place so
hope you'll join me this Saturday I've
been rambling for a long time now so
this Saturday livestream me happy fun
guy not depressing in any way so thank
you all so much for watching click in
the link in the description below there
is a link to my twitch channel follow me
there you'll know exactly when we go
live I will let you guys know the
charity we do closer to the date this
weekend so thank you again for watching
and just make this a great year been a
great pasture I know we're gonna do
incredible things you know thank you
again and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye